when SpaceX started I think the first
three rocket launches weren't successful
yeah and and the fourth one was what
would have happened if the fourth one
hadn't worked we would have failed yeah
but let's talk about that one of the
failures were spectacular I mean I would
go out to the island the cars alone with
you know and seeing giant exploding
Rockets is quite an amazing sight and I
was one of the only investors in SpaceX
and I said you know what if all I get to
do is to see these rockets explode well
worth every dime I put in
[Laughter]
[Music]
there's something to be said about
brotherly support but it was an amazing
thing to watch what he done Wood had
built with those rockets in I mean on a
shoestring in the middle of nowhere and
literally the middle of the Pacific two
thousand miles from Hawaii and that
experience we'd fly on these these what
are they called the if you ease you'll
find the Huey's you feel like you're
right out of out of Apocalypse Now
flying to dr. Evil's island really
amazing I mean and again worth every
penny still to this day I'd say so I I
think the failures were actually
unbelievably exciting to be part of rule
number two
keep looking for new opportunities with
Kevin O'Leary I was working once in an
ice-cream parlor when I was about 15
years old my first real job and on the
second day I was asked to scrape the gum
off between the Mexican tiles on the
floor and I said to the woman who owned
the storms called Magoo's ice cream
parlor you didn't hire me to scrape gum
you hired me to scoop ice cream and this
this girl the shoe store across the way
that's looking at me I don't want to see
her you're scraping the gum and she said
what you're talking about I own this
store I'll do anything I want with you
get down on your knees and scrape that
gum when I said I'm not doing it
she said you're fired last job I ever
had I owe that woman everything
I don't like to work for people many of
you would hear I hope inherit that
there's nothing wrong with it but you
want to control your own destiny you
work for yourself that's how it works
I'm trying to inspire those of you are
on the tipping point take the chance
you're young go for it
there's nothing better than being able
to wake up in the morning 10 years of 20
years so now and do what ever you like
it it's about freedom that's what
matters
I'm not saying being an employee's bad
but believe me being an entrepreneur is
better I'm a little biased
rule number three be willing to be
misunderstood with Jeff Bezos we would
be very naive to believe that we're not
going to be criticized I mean that's
just part of the terrain you have to
accept that when I tell people is if
you're gonna be we're gonna do anything
new or innovative you have to be willing
to be misunderstood if you cannot if you
can't afford to be misunderstood then
for goodness sake don't do anything new
or innovative rule number four use the
95/5 rule with Tim Ferriss you know the
ninety nine ninety five five rule there
are no spare you know ninety five
percent of everything we do is right
every day in business but look for the
five percent you do wrong and that's
what makes you better than everybody
else there are no spare customers okay
it's a competitive world and every one
of our businesses take no out of your
damn vocabulary you you're on a business
trip and it's 11:02 you hang up the
phone and and on a call and you call
down to order some breakfast and they
saw I'm sorry sir we don't serve
breakfast anymore that's okay no problem
I don't need a waffle or or an eggs
benedict just throw a couple eggs and a
skillet and send them up scrambled
however is easy for you to do I'm sorry
sir we don't serve breakfast why are you
telling me no I didn't ask you for
anything special you're going to throw a
burger in the pan just throw me a couple
of eggs and take care of me B you're in
the hospitality business okay and you're
telling
me know and everybody's in the
hospitality business no matter what they
do you take care of your customer okay
you take care of your customers it's no
different than we walk in and your
people meet us polite you put a welcome
up on the screen you come in here
everybody couldn't be can I get you some
water
tell me can can I do this for you you're
in the service business absolutely why
do you want to be an ass and say no to
somebody when it's just as easy to say
yes or just given up her the company's
being run by somebody who's not also if
you want to have more confidence and
self-love check out my 254 series
they're free the link to join find the
description below the stress primarily
comes from not taking action you work
for yourself that's how it works the
only thing that stops you from getting
what you want in life is the [ __ ]
story you tell yourself rule number five
be resourceful with Daymond John when
you were again in the early days yeah at
one point you only had ten shirts
how did you utilize the power of broke
to get the word out so you know when you
you know Jay Abraham who you know is
really my mentor he loves to say opium
is other people's manufacturing manpower
marketing mentors and you can make money
off other people's mistakes and I took
inventory of myself and I knew I wanted
to get into this area of business but my
inventory was that my liabilities were I
knew nothing about manufacturing but my
assets were that everybody was shooting
these little videos around the
neighborhood they weren't like these big
ditty videos at a million dollars I mean
this guy this was like you know guy with
a little camcorder or something and I
knew that these people wanted they
needed clothing and when they would have
the Nike send stuff to them Nike didn't
appreciate them so I would go to the set
and see an LL Cool J and I would be I
would say only said 18 hours I get
kicked off with three or four of those
sets but the one time that somebody
allowed me to put a shirt on them I put
a shirt on them and then I would take it
back and I would keep putting on
different rappers and different rappers
and different taking it back in and I
made sure that I didn't dry clean these
things so they made sure they gave them
back because they stink
so I knew yeah I get that yeah sure
doing right now but these videos start
to rotate and you know corporate America
didn't understand the power of videos at
that time and I started becoming known
as a huge cult I mean while I'm still a
waiter in Baldwin Long Island and I have
these ten little stinky t-shirts in my
basement
but I was doing something I love I would
have went on those video sets for free I
was talking to a video chick I was
eating the free food over there I was
watching ol Dirty Bastard be ol Dirty
Bastard so you know I would have paid to
be in those sets yeah Oh Joe some that
look rule number six pay attention to
history with Mark Cuban when you have a
good idea right you ask your friends you
ask for feedback around you said oh I'm
all excited it's a great idea my friends
liked it I can't like what do you do
next
you go to Google right and you put it in
there and you say it's this this this
this this you find 50 different keyword
searches and you see there's nothing
there right Wow there must be it must be
a great idea no one else is doing it
wrong the reason there's nothing there
is the 15 people did it before you are
out of business they're web servers are
down and they're not indexed anymore and
there's no sense of history and a lot of
the things that are happening you know
because and particularly with mobile
apps because there's no real web there
there's like a one-page website up that
directs you to the mobile app there's
nothing indexing the app and so a lot of
50 different people are doing the same
app and you know and because you can't
get a URL it's you know the xxxx app
right and it's xxx app and it's hard to
find the comparables and it's hard to
learn from the history of it and so it's
whether it's Google whether it's
Facebook the real challenge right now on
starting a company is you can't learn
from history because all the history is
gone and I sold at least have that maybe
it yeah holds us back and maybe you know
it's the worst thing that could happen
is you know being you know ignorant of
what happened Mike you know is probably
better in a lot of cases and but
sometimes it's not and so I think that's
one of the biggest challenges that
entrepreneurs face today that there's no
history to really go back to look at
rule number seven play to win with Dan
Pena
so when you start playing not to lose
like an army anything you're up 18
you're six at halftime you lose my man
on the game ties in 1818 by the end of
the fourth quarter and you're losing
overtime because you stopped playing to
win in the second half and you start
playing not to lose that's the same a
good news because you start worrying
about the few players that you made and
you start to sit on like a mother hand
mostly women and women in this room that
have been in business stops playing to
win long ago and they started playing
not to lose rule number eight maintain
your assets with Jordan Balfour it often
you think when you're younger or even
you're old if you haven't had this this
lesson taught you the hard way is that I
could be half pregnant when it comes to
ethics notice I could be ethical but
maybe I could step over the line nodes
and get away with it yeah the problem
with that is that when you step over the
ethical line once your line of ethics
moves a bit mm-hmm so next time you step
over you'll still have it further or
further so with me you know I became
desensitized to essentially writing
wrong behavior and it's very easy I'm
Walsh you and a lot of people as you as
we found out in 2007 it wasn't just me
everyone Oh even but 50 times bigger
than what you and some of these guys
cost a lot of people my ways I you know
I always say everyone's doing it that's
the old excuse surely do it you should I
did what I did it was wrong but the
point was it's very easy to point say
well everyone's doing it so you have to
that's such a good point you have to
maintain your at that you really do
there's no how do you do that very
simple it really is very simple you just
don't take the first step Kotter that's
it and that's the secret there's no way
you could take you can't like just take
a step and a blur than be a good person
it's very very hard rule number nine
specialize with Patrick Bateman when
companies get bigger they all of a
sudden want to be everything to
everybody right what we're gonna sell
this and we're gonna sell this and we're
gonna sell this and we're gonna sell
this and we're gonna sell this no
problem let them do it that's when you
catch up because for you you let
collides general
you specialize you specialize you
specialize in one area
let them generalize and then when
they're generalizing they're grown like
this but you're grown like this and then
you catch up when you're specializing
then all of a sudden oh you decide at
that moment what things to pivot but
you've got to catch up in order to catch
up to your guy or gal that you're
competing against
you got to specialize don't get caught
up trying to be everything to everybody
and sell every single product and rule
number ten the last one before a very
special bonus clip is be the most
dependable person with Grant Cardone I
would tell my 25 year old self dude do
whatever you have to do to make sure you
don't ruin your name you have to be the
most dependable person anybody knows
starting with yourself you have to be
the person you depend on okay so if
smoking weed on the weekends or drinking
or having hangovers or hanging out with
those people like makes you feel less
about yourself less you have less trust
for you something you've got to knock
those things off when this is done maybe
make a list no no make a list don't
maybe make a list of things that you
need to knock off that destroy your own
personal sense of trust in yourself this
is a big thing that I did when I was 25
I started doing whatever I told somebody
I would do I was gonna do if I told you
I was gonna punch you in the mouth a
punch in the mouth right then okay if I
told you I was gonna be there at 4
o'clock I'd be there early if I told you
I was gonna stay late I would stay late
whatever it was I started building trust
back within myself because the reality
is nobody's gonna trust me I had
destroyed so much trust and respect with
others and told them over and over again
oh it's it's gonna be different this
time so old 25-year old grant rebuild
the trust you have in yourself and keep
doing that until other people start
saying hey you changed you're different
now and that hurt that started happened
in literally within about three to six
months of me starting to make that
commitment to say hey I'm gonna start
rebuilding my own personal trust in
myself my personal self-esteem came up I
wasn't using drugs anymore I wouldn't
use an alcohol anymore
going out on weekends I was working when
my friends were playing now I've got a
special bonus rule on how to live in the
trenches with Gary Vaynerchuk that I
think you're gonna enjoy but before that
it's time for the three point landing
questions let's go from just watching
the video to take in action here we go
question number one how can you be the
most dependable person to someone this
week number two where do you need to
better specialize and number three how
can you maintain your positivity today
one of the great reasons my company does
well is there's not a single person that
works at vaynermedia that does the work
more than I do as the CEO of my company
there's not one employee that works for
me that produces more content deploys
more ads like I'm living in the trenches
I'm a practitioner I'm in meetings
sometimes what the platforms were I'm
correcting their mistake of what their
platform can do
if you want to see the seven lessons
from billionaire entrepreneurs check out
the video right there next to me I think
you'll enjoy it continue to believe and
I'll see you there
you should never feel comfortable you
should be happy and dissatisfied too
many of you are sitting around waiting
to feel ready